amazing writers amazing cast and crew of
people this is a dream come true you
don't you don't ever think you're going
to get to a point like this
kaylee cuoco just revealed how she
learned the big bang theory was coming
to an
end and admits she was totally
blindsided the heart wants what the
heart wants leonard
okay the actress covers the golden
globes issue of variety
and inside she reveals how she learns
that the hit sitcom would end
after its 12th season she explains that
she and her co-star johnny galecki had
discussed returning for a 13th season
and they both
really wanted to do it but then she says
the show's creator chuck lorre
called the cast into his office at the
start of filming season
12 where kaylee says their other co-star
jim parsons
said quote i don't think i can continue
on it's the logical fallacy of extending
someone's argument to ridiculous
proportions and then criticizing the
result and i do not appreciate it the 35
year old actress said she was quote
shocked and blown away by jim's
statement and according to kaylee
chuck said they wouldn't move forward
without the whole team
that was the one thing we all agreed on
we came in together
we go out together okay it's not me
right this script is terrible
yeah i had higher hopes for a movie
called
serial apist 2 monkey c monkey kill
and while the final episode aired in may
2019
kaylee who earned 1 million dollars per
episode of the series
says it forever changed her life for the
better
quote it was a blessing i was able to
take care of a lot of things in my life
and my family and i will forever be
grateful for that
kaylee adds that she will always
appreciate earning the same salary as
her male counterparts on big bang
because it set a standard for her will
you have dinner with me
okay that was like a super cute moment
but we're really not
supposed to do that soon now kaylee is
both the star
and executive producer of hbo max's the
flight attendant
which nabbed her her first ever golden
globes nomination for both best actress
in a tv series musical or comedy
and best tv series musical or comedy
[Music]
why was this though the right thing for
you to do post big bang
when you were choosing like what's going
to define me after what has defined me
for 12 years
in the you know i still don't know if it
was right or wrong
it was but i still i told you this for
years i have a very strong gut feeling
and when i saw this book
and i was thinking of what the next
project would be do i want to do i want
to option something
what do i wanna do when i saw this book
and i read this girl i thought oh my god
this would make a really fascinating tv
character i just thought that it would
and that's that's what i thought and i
thought hey anyone want to make this
with me
then all of a sudden i was in new york
shooting it so
got a great team and three years later
it's amazing to see this come to life
because it really has been my baby i've
never been with anything from the
beginning
you